foreign
.com exclusive
it's Power 98.3 man you already know kk4
we in here
I got my dude with me right now man this
dude came from Atlanta to mess with us
today in Phoenix Arizona y'all make some
noise y'all already got me laughing in
here if people could only understand the
stuff we talk about off the air while
they listening to records while we're
here talking about just current events
and laughing our asses yeah shout out to
Charles Ramsey man Charles
Ramsey man is hilarious man I was just
checking that out all right so Luda man
uh the last time I chopped it up with
you man was probably a little bit uh it
was Memorial Day Weekend actually yeah
man you got you got your pockets are a
little fatter this time because you know
what I mean you got your little
promotion you need to move to a whole
new city another favorite city of mine
Phoenix so I'm just I gotta ask what are
you doing with this this newfound money
what you saving up for me you know I'm
just uh you know just just spending a
lot of money on strippers that's what I
was gonna say because that's what I do
and a Molly's and yeah
I always stay halfway broke just because
that same reason man no I know man you
know I'm just I'm just chilling man you
know getting my kids some stuff you know
what I'm saying you know what I mean I'm
not mad at that at all the last time he
spoke man you had the jingling record
out yes sir you put out the up-tempo
joint the the top 40 friendly record
which is skipping my mind what it was
called that's the rest of my life that's
that's for the movie it's at the end of
the movie okay so we shot that in Europe
and we're putting out all this free
music so basically while I was shooting
the movie over there I just wanted to
continue to put out free music that's
why we dropping a record every Friday
before we start giving them the album
music okay so all of this stuff is
feeding the audience and really
appreciation for all the fans that's
been supporting me for the past 10 years
you know what I mean you got some songs
for the strip club you got some songs
for the car you got some songs for for
the radios a little bit everything it's
just a mixture of stuff hey I want to
ask man ludiversal what is the status
because I know you was prepping the
little I know I heard some records man
uh you know PK played me some joints
that I was really excited about now we
got a lot of Records I know the Versa is
coming towards the fall but that's what
I was saying while I was overseas
shooting the movie for six months it was
only but so much I could do we was over
there for six months and really that's
how that old the whole rest of my life
record with Usher came about because you
know EDM is real popular over there in
Europe we shot the whole fast and
furious six movie in Europe so basically
it was kind of like you know I was a
product of my environment we got out
there we got inspired trying to go into
those clubs and you're like you know
what I'm gonna make some of this this
pumpery right yeah man Ibiza out there
and doing that so it fits perfectly in
the movie when you see it and the movie
comes out May 24th and since we talking
about all this music the mixtape IDGAF
drops on the same day so next next same
day next Friday we got a little mixtape
next Friday the movie man I told you we
were talking about this off the air you
know you of course were a part of the
good fast and furious yeah yeah yeah and
then the Bow Wow one came out and I was
I was done with the franchise I never
even saw that one to be honest with you
it's not a damn shame that I skipped not
a damn shame right you should be very
lucky you didn't see that movie I will
never get that time back in my life you
just do before the money that I spent to
go to that movie but uh anyway you have
it no um you're you actually uh I feel
like the the franchise is better than
ever man like listen our last three
movies have been crazy yeah I'm gonna
keep it real with you man like because
you do you keep it real and I appreciate
you for that Fast Five the last one in
my opinion just reinvigorated the entire
franchise one it was damn near like part
one yeah that's why that's why we're
doing it right now in fast six like I
said comes out May 24th and you need
this is a movie experience like you have
to go to the movie theater to see this
movie this isn't a bootleg type thing
you don't wanna you don't want to go to
go get the bootleg for me you don't want
to do that put the camera and put more
money in bootleg bootleg chaos pocket
you don't want to do that no what I was
gonna say was man this is uh it's an
experience and the crazy thing is I
think the cat is out the back they are
already
yeah another one they're writing fast
seven as we speak so I can't be mad as a
black man that you know I didn't get
killed off yet I'm very happy that I did
you got to be in part seven yeah I gotta
be in part seven it ain't killing me yet
man I'm good I'm good in the game so far
um all right so uh you just kind of gave
us a little spoiler uh Ludacris is not
getting killed in Fast and Furious six
exactly but in this franchise you can
die it seems like you can come back to
life yeah shout out to uh Michelle
Rodriguez yeah it's back in this thing
all right so um you're shooting a movie
with the rock man which he's I'm a
wrestling geek bro like hardcore like me
and my kid geek out to Monday Night Raw
every Monday yeah
um was it like
when I know that you're kind of swollen
swollen up a little bit when you were
you kind of inspired you know what I'm
saying hanging out with the Rocks hit
them weights you literally just said it
man you cannot be around the Rock and
Vin Diesel for six months and not do any
damn thing I almost like just gained
muscle just by kicking it with them it's
as simple as that you can just be around
them you gonna come out like 20 pounds
of muscle like heavier yeah just being
around them so I had to get in the gym I
couldn't compete on a mass or a weight
level so I just tried to get ripped up
man and I think the ladies when you go
see this movie you might be a surprise
on a certain scene in this movie is a
bunch of special effects and I've been
using steroids for the past six months
so I'm just being about to meet you
about to be yoked up in this new movie
yoked up man yo they put my face on
another person's body I'm real happy
they really did man I'm just she's like
nah man I work for those muscles man you
can't you can't believe everything I say
something well you know sometimes you
have some great videos you know with the
with the big you know with the exact
hands on the videos you know that's true
I got my get back video arms in Fast and
Furious six so you'll get to see that
all right so um you have been dropping
new music uh every Friday you have a new
song that just came out today produced
by bank I love it man my favorite song
on the mixtape as you said it's your
favorite song too so I'm seeing I see
great mindset mixtape was dope um what
we're gonna do man is we're gonna go to
hit commercials right now we're gonna
come back we're gonna play a couple
looter Classics we got them in studio
fast and furious six dropping this dude
is in it and Fast and Furious 7 is
already on the way yeah man mixtape like
I said free music for all the fans
before we get to the little virtual
album which is out number eight so I'm
just happy to still be hungry and still
passionate about this music game and I
love it if y'all got questions for
Ludacris hit us up 2606 983 is in studio
you can hit us on the Twitter at bootleg
cab at Power 983